you may remember about gosh it's got to
be about eight months or so ago I went
on Jordan Peterson's new daily wire show
it was the first episode of the show and
we talked all about parenting and in in
a certain sense we were talking about
gay parenting and the challenges
specifically related to that but then we
broadened it to to what the purpose of
parenting is all together somebody put
together this nice uh minute-long little
uh snippet of that chat with Jordan
when you have a a baby say it's you
can't believe it
and you can't believe that you're going
to be able to figure out what to do with
this thing like it's like it's the most
complicated thing you've ever had and no
one has helped you figure out how to do
it so you're stuck and then like three
months later it's like you can't really
imagine what life would be like without
that baby and then it's sort of like
this goes on forever that's how it feels
but it doesn't right you have little
kids for four years so you miss it at
your peril and you don't get it back and
that's not I know what with your career
you miss opportunities you fall behind
this happens to women a lot it's part of
the reason for the pay Gap and it's
really hard on women you know although
no one knows what to do about it for
women it often seems that no matter what
they do it's wrong right they stay home
with the kids it's wrong if they go to
work it's wrong if they do both it's
wrong and I'm like I'm not being smart
about that that's rough man but uh but
having said all that I would say again
you got little kids for four years
don't miss it you will regret it
which one of those Rings more true to
you what Jordan just said there
or what Chelsea Handler was saying
previously like you all just kind of
fundamentally know it I am in no way
mocking people that don't have children
I had 46 years on this Earth without
children I probably should have done it
earlier and we've rushed to have two
quickly because I wanted to be able to
play catch with them before I'm too old
you know what I mean but there is
something bizarrely
connected to modern feminism and this
thing that we should only go for
happiness and it's all about us and
there isn't anything grander and we
should throw away all the things of the
past and then at the end is it leading
someone like her to happiness like I get
she has a lot of money and she can smoke
a joint in a hot tub and Drug her nieces
and nephews and things of that nature
and that's all well and good but that
there perhaps is something more
important here about The Human
Experience going on anyway it was
causing a real uh Firestorm on the
internet I wanted to give my two cents
on that I would love to hear your
thoughts
thank you
foreign
[Music]